bienvenidos en este vídeo lo que quiero
hacer es darles una introducción muy
básica a la trigonometría trigonometría
quizás ya conozcan la palabra o quizás
conozcan incluso un poco de
trigonometría pero para los que no saben
la palabra trigonometría en la parte de
trigo habla de triángulos y en la parte
demetrio habla de medidas la
trigonometría es el estudio de las
proporciones de los lados de un
triángulo vamos a comenzar con un
triángulo rectángulo es decir un
triángulo en el que uno de sus ángulos
es un ángulo recto
digamos este triángulo de aquí y voy a
suponer que este de aquí es mi ángulo
recto
este es un ángulo
recto y que es un ángulo recto pues
simplemente es un ángulo que mide 90
grados posteriormente veremos otras
formas de medir ángulos pero por ahora
nos basta con decir eso y vamos a
ponerle medidas a los lados vamos a
decir que este lado aquí a esta altura
mide 3 y vamos a suponer que esta base
este lado del triángulo
vale 4
y si están de acuerdo podemos decir qué
esto de aquí este lado el más grande
vale 5 este lado se llama la hipotenusa
es el lado al que abre el ángulo de 90
grados decimos que este ángulo de 90
grados se obtiene de este lado y en
realidad sólo podemos hablar de
hipotenusa cuando tenemos triángulos
rectángulos así que está como decía se
llama la hipotenusa
incidentalmente estos dos otros lados se
llaman catetos y bien nosotros sabemos
de geometría que en estos triángulos se
vale el teorema de pitágoras así que yo
sé que 3 al cuadrado que es la longitud
al cuadrado de este cateto más la
longitud al cuadrado de este cateto que
sería 4 al cuadrado siempre me tiene que
dar la longitud de la hipotenusa al
cuadrado esto siempre es cierto en estos
triángulos bien pues en trigonometría
tenemos tres funciones centrales tenemos
el seno que se abrevia sen tenemos
también el coste no que sea breve a cos
y tenemos también la tangente que
ustedes adivinaron se veía tan
y bien estas funciones trigonométricas
seno coseno y tangente lo que nos dicen
son ciertas relaciones que hay entre las
magnitudes de estos lados del triángulo
rectángulo esto solo vale para
triángulos rectángulos ahora les voy a
dar una pequeña mnemotecnia que verán
que es muy muy útil en la trigonometría
en general vamos a decir
cat
y después todas
ok ok a todas y que nos dice esto pues
nos va a decir que el pse no es igual a
opuesto entre hipotenusa y en un segundo
les digo que significa eso deme un
segundo para acabar de escribir esto acá
nos va a decir que el cose no es igual a
adyacente entre hipotenusa benz c a h y
tangente tangente
nos va a decir que tangente es igual a
opuesto entre adyacente y qué quiere
decir esto pues para verlo seleccionemos
un ángulo en mi triángulo rectángulo por
ejemplo podríamos tomar este ángulo como
el ángulo theta y lo que las funciones
trigonométricas seno cosen y tangente
van a hacer es asociar los ciertos
números a este ángulo theta veamos por
ejemplo qué pasa si considero él
seno
el seno de theta pues por definición el
seno es opuesto entre hipotenusa que
significa esto este lado de aquí es el
opuesto a teta porque teta abre hacia
ese lado fíjense que este ángulo el
ángulo teta está comprendido entre el
lado que mide 4 el cateto que mide 4 y
la hipotenusa que mide 5 el otro lado es
el lado opuesto al ángulo teta es más
déjenme lo escribo esté aquí es el lado
opuesto opuesto
y este de aquí
el lado que vale 4 sería el lado
adyacente adyacente
y esto solo vale cuando estoy hablando
de tetas y cambio de ángulo entonces
cambian por ejemplo si considerara este
otro ángulo entonces este lado que vale
4 sería el opuesto y este acá vale 3
sería el adyacente para este ángulo pero
estoy hablando de teta teta abre hacia
el lado que vale 3 así que este es el
lado opuesto de modo que el seno de teta
vale cuanto vale mi lado opuesto pues
como dije vale 3 y lo tengo que dividir
entre cuánto vale la hipotenusa que es 5
así que el seno de teta es igual a tres
quintos y de hecho algo que voy a ver
más adelante en algún otro vídeo es que
esto es independiente del triángulo para
cualquier ángulo teta si el ángulo es
igual aunque el triángulo fuera más
chico si el ángulo es igual
la función se nos va a tomar exactamente
el mismo valor no depende del triángulo
que esté usando depende del ángulo es
así depende el ángulo pero no del
triángulo del tamaño del tengo lo
digamos de la escala
si se quiere ok pero después de toda esa
discusión
cuánto vale el coseno de teta pues el
coseno es adyacente entre hipotenusa el
lado adyacente como decía vale 4
vale 4 entre la hipotenusa la hipotenusa
de nuevo vale 5
fíjense que la hipotenusa siempre es la
hipotenusa esa no cambia aunque cambie
el ángulo
y finalmente la tangente
cuánto vale la tangente de theta pues
vale lo que vale el lado opuesto que
vale 3
/ lo que vale el lado adyacente que es 4
estos serían los valores de mis tres
funciones trigonométricas de hecho hay
más funciones trigonométricas pero más
adelante veremos que se pueden derivar
de estas tres por eso les decía que
estas tres eran las centrales ok
bueno pensemos en otro ángulo en mi
triángulo para tener un poco más de
espacio voy a copiar este triángulo acá
abajo vamos a decir que ese es mi lado
que vale tres están hipotenusa y este es
el lado que vale cuatro quizás se me dé
forma un poco pero creo que no habrá
problema 3 4 y 5 y aquí está mi ángulo
recto ahora vamos a pensar en vez de
theta vamos a considerar este ángulo
este ángulo de aquí lo voy a llamar x
así que x sería este ángulo que está acá
arriba
y de nuevo vamos a empezar
preguntándonos por cuanto es el seno de
x pues ahora quién es el cateto opuesto
quien es el lado opuesto a x x ahora
abre hacia este lado hacia el lado que
vale 4 digamos acá antes el lado opuesto
a theta era este lado que vale 3 el
verde aquí pero ahora que estoy
considerando a x el lado opuesto ya no
es este que vale 3 sino este que vale 4
es más vamos a decir que éste
este es el ahora el opuesto opuesto
entonces cuánto vale el seno de x pues
vale la magnitud del lado opuesto que es
4 dividido entre la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa no cambia 4 entre 5 a y está
bien ahora cuánto vale el coseno de x
pues el coseno por su cato a es coseno
igual adyacente entre hipotenusa el
adyacente de x ya no vale 4 ahora vale 3
es uno de los lados que lo encierran
digamos así que ahora este lado que vale
3 es el lado adyacente o cateto
adyacente recuerden lo que les dije
depende de qué ángulo estén considerando
cuál es su lado opuesto y cuál es su
lado adyacente así que el coseno de x va
a ser 3
entre la hipotenusa que de nuevo vale 5
y finalmente cuánto vale la tangente la
tangente de x la tangente del ángulo x
pues ahora quién es mi lado opuesto es 4
de nuevo toda su cato tangente es igual
a opuesto entre adyacente así que para x
el opuesto vale 4 y el adyacente vale 3
así que la tangente de x vale 4 tercios
y bueno con esto ya terminamos este
vídeo en el próximo haría una cantidad
muy grande de ejemplos para que nos
familiaricemos con esto pero les quiero
dejar la pregunta qué pasa cuando x se
hace muy grande que pasa cuando x por
ejemplo se acerca a 90 grados o cuando
es mayor a 90 grados en ese caso la
definición de soca tohá no nos va a
servir de mucho y la vamos a tener que
extender la vamos a modificar para poder
definir las funciones trigonométricas de
cualquier ángulo y no solo de ángulos
que están entre 0 y 90 grados